[Musik]
deutschland im shutdown heute werden
fast 1000 corona tote gemeldet
im bundestag verteidigt die kanzlerin
ihre maßnahmen urteil im charlie hebdo
prozess nach dem anschlag auf das
französische satiremagazin müssen
mehrere islamistische terrorhelfer lange
ins gefängnis und ein ort für austausch
und vielfalt im neu aufgebauten berliner
stadtschloss öffnet das umweltforum
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers und hinein und danke
dass sie bei uns sind an diesem
besonderen mittwoch in deutschland sport
nachher in der sendung mit kristin otto
vor allem mit viel handball genannt es
ist der tag an dem dieses land in den
shutdown geht die meisten schulen und
geschäfte zu das öffentliche leben soll
weitgehend herunter gefahren werden im
kampf gegen die pandemie
und so sieht es jetzt also aus in dieser
vorweihnachtszeit
das hier ist erfurt hier sind die
einkaufsstraßen genauso verweist wie
hier in münchen
die meisten läden zu und das hier ist
hamburg die wenigen verbliebenen
glühweinbuden abgebaut wie dringend die
lage ist zeigt diese zahl des
robert-koch-instituts 952 neue
todesfälle
da sind auch nachgereichte fälle aus
sachsen vom vortag dabei aber ohne die
auch ohne die wäre es ein neuer
höchststand
was zu tun ist und wie es weitergeht
auch in sachen impfen
darum ging es heute im bundestag andreas
künast aus berlin
das corona ein großer schwindel sein
soll und die tausenden toten eine große
lüge
die kanzlerin wird heute fragen
beantworten darunter die ihrer
schärfsten gegner aber nicht vor dem
bundestag sondern drinnen in der
kanzler- befragung beschuldigt auch die
afg merkel der bevölkerung nicht die
wahrheit zu sagen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie beabsichtigen
um eine immunisierung der bevölkerung zu
erreichen alle einwohner unseres
vaterlandes zu impfen
dann behauptet die afd der impfstoff von
bayern tag sei gentechnisch manipuliert
und schütze nicht vor einer infektion
merkel widerspricht deutlich und dann
würde ich sie bitten der sache dem
sachverhalt entsprechend nicht von
irgendwelchen genmanipulierten dingen zu
sprechen das ist ein impfstoff der
genetische komponenten enthält
und damit sehr präzise funktionieren
könnte jeder bürger werde die wahl haben
sagt merkel zu niemand müsse sich impfen
lassen aber wenn das mehr als 40 50 60
prozent der bevölkerung seien solchen
dann werden wir noch sehr lange eine
maske tragen müssen es war sehr viel
länger als das weil wir dann die
herdenimmunität nicht erreichen
bis auf die afd werben alle parteien für
vertrauen in die impfung fdp und linke
fordern aber ein impf gesetz vertrauen
schafft man nur mit transparenz und
demokratischer willensbildung in die
parlamente also vor den augen der
öffentlichkeit und das fordern nein ich
meine das ist immer während wir die
debatte führen beklagen sie sich dass
wir die debatte nicht führen
also es ist es ist ein transparentes
verfahren die hohen infektionszahlen
zwingen auch den bundestag zu
drastischer kontakt reduzierung die
sitzung am freitag ist abgesagt
es stecken sich weiterhin viel zu viele
menschen mit dem virus an das sind die
gemeldeten positiv testergebnisse das
robert koch institut meldet 27 1728 neue
fälle
auch hier sind die fehlenden zahlen aus
sachsen von gestern dabei insgesamt sind
das sechs 1913 mehr als am mittwoch
vergangener woche sehr viele menschen
stecken sich immer noch in alten und
pflegeheimen an es trifft immer noch
gerade die verwundbarsten besonders hart
auch unter den corona toten sind
überdurchschnittlich viele von ihnen
trotz aller appelle und ankündigungen
ist ihre situation bislang nicht im
griff wie volker check zeigt 99
einzelzimmer fünf appartements elf
doppelzimmer das caritas-altenheim im
bayerischen unterhaching für unser
kamerateam ist schluss an der haustür
die 119 bewohner und ihre betreuer haben
angst vor einer corona ansteckung eine
schnelle impfung noch in diesem jahr
darauf hoffen hier viele gerade in den
altenheimen nicht mehr noch viele viele
monate mit der korona pandemie
beschäftigt seine von daher ist es ein
ganz hoffnungsvolles zeichen aber halt
noch mit vielen fragezeichen wie wir das
auch wiederum noch umsetzen sollen
trotz der vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie
schnelltests in den altenheimen holen
sich immer noch sehr viele bewohner eine
tödliche infektion
bis gestern waren deutschlandweit fast
50.000 bewohner von alten- und
pflegeheim am virus erkrankt 6700 21
patienten starben an und mit dem virus
das entspricht einer quote von 13,6
prozent
letzte vorbereitungen am fliegerhorst im
bayerischen penzing hier üben die
johanniter den impf einsatz im altenheim
bei bedarf können sie schnell ausrücken
die altenheime werden sich bei uns
melden und uns die daten übermitteln und
die anzahl der impfwilligen bürger
kritisch die lage auf den
intensivstationen auch im oberlausitzer
bergland klinikum in zittau
berichten zufolge hat ein mediziner in
einem online-forum erzählt dass zwar oft
versucht werde patienten zu verlegen für
transport unfähige erkrankte könne es
unter umständen aber keine hilfe geben
die klinik bestätigt oder dementiert die
schilderung des arztes nicht
ausdrücklich
corona alltag in den krankenhäusern wie
hier im brandenburgischen senftenberg
werden transportfähige patienten
ausgeflogen um anderen platz zu machen
steigende corona zahlen auch in vielen
unserer nachbarländer aber auch sehr
unterschiedliche arten damit umzugehen
beispiel schweiz die neuinfektionen
liegen dort extrem hoch die
krankenhäuser sind voll und trotzdem
sind die antike ohne regeln
vergleichsweise lachs läden restaurants
hotels und vor allem die skigebiete sind
geöffnet es gibt lediglich eine
abendliche sperrstunde
ganz anders die bilder aus london die
sonst so wuselige metropole wird
dichtgemacht kinos theater pubs
restaurants schließen ab heute komplett
und treffen mit anderen haushalten den
innenräumen sind verboten
und wie sieht es bei uns aus welche
rechte und pflichten hat man im shutdown
diese frage klärt ein zdf spezial gleich
nach uns und in unserer app erklären wir
interaktiv wie die impfung funktioniert
und was dabei genau im körper
passiert unser nächstes thema heute
abend in frankreich sind die urteile
gesprochen worden im charlie hebdo
prozess für die hauptzeit für den
hauptangeklagten 30 jahre haft vor knapp
sechs jahren hatten islamisten das
satireblatt angegriffen und einen
koscheren supermarkt menschen weltweit
zeigten anteilnahme über die anschläge
mit 17 toten bei denen niemand der heute
verurteilten direkt dabei war
doch das gericht sagt ohne sie hätte es
die terroranschläge nicht gegeben
christel haas am tag des urteils titelt
die satirezeitschrift charlie hebdo gott
ist in die schranken verwiesen meint
religion darf nie verbrechen
rechtfertigen
in diesem saal fiel heute das strafmaß
für 14 hintermänner der attentate von
es reicht von 4 bis 30 jahre haft einen
terroristischen hintergrund sieht das
gericht bei mehreren angeklagten aber
nicht als erwiesen an
diese diese entscheidung stellt klar
ohne hintermänner gibt es kein attentat
ohne sie gibt es keinen terrorismus und
alle die in diesem dunstkreis unterwegs
sind können sehr schwer bestraft werden
januar 2015
zwei attentäter dringen in die räume von
charlie ob du ein erschießen zwölf
menschen unter ihnen die bekanntesten
karikaturisten frankreichs ich zitterte
erklärt die überlebende zeichnerin coco
dem gericht nach den schüssen war da
dieser stille diese totenstille
zwei tage später nimmt ein weiterer
terrorist geiseln in einem koscheren
supermarkt vier menschen starben
der prozess ist der versuch ein
nationales trauma aufzuarbeiten
dieser prozess war wichtig weil in
unserem land die grundfreiheiten
angegriffen worden sind er macht klar
dass wir an diesen freiheiten und am
recht festhalten
doch während der prozess noch läuft gibt
es neuen terror in frankreich
messerangriff vor den ehemaligen
redaktionsräumen von charlie hebdo
enthauptung eines lehrers und anschlag
auf eine kirche in nizza mit dem urteil
heute wird ein schmerzhaftes kapitel
geschlossen
doch die terrorbedrohung bleibt
seit vier monaten kämpfen zehntausende
menschen in belarus für freiheit und
demokratie und gegen machthaber
alexander lukaschenko
das eu parlament hat die belarussische
opposition heute mit dem sacharow-preis
ausgezeichnet
die ehemalige präsidentschaftskandidatin
svetlana die hanowski nahm ihn entgegen
stellvertretend für alle die woche für
woche trotz der gewalt der
sicherheitskräfte gegen das regime
protestieren
anne gellinek berichtet da habe ich
friedlich und entschlossen
noch immer gehen die belarussen jeden
sonntag auf die straße
trotz wasserwerfern polizei gewalt und
verhaftungen
sie demonstrieren gegen den autoritär
regierenden langzeit präsidenten
alexander lukaschenko und für freie
wahlen galionsfiguren des widerstands
sind frauen die
präsidentschaftskandidatin svitlana
tiefbahnhofs kaya oder die musikerin
maria callas nico war auch ihren mut und
ihr durchhaltevermögen zeichnet das
europaparlament mit dem sacharow preis
aus die opposition ist geschwächt fast
alle sind inzwischen ins exil gedrängt
worden oder sie sitzen in haft sowie
callies nico war für sie nimmt ihre
schwester an der preisverleihung in
brüssel teil
sie sitzt mit drei anderen frauen in
einer zelle in einem alten sowjet
gefängnis aber sie versucht optimistisch
zu bleiben obwohl sie in letzter zeit
keine briefe mehr bekommt und sie ihr
die bücher weggenommen haben
maria freue sich über den preis sie sei
erleichtert dass europa die über 150
politischen gefangenen in belarus nicht
vergesse es wird landowsky wünscht sich
in ihrer dankesrede weitere
unterstützung der belarussischen
opposition durch europa denn gedauert
schrieb ohne ein freies belarus kann
auch europa nicht vollends frei sein für
belarus gibt es kein zurück schreibt
auch die inhaftierte collies nico war
der applaus des europaparlaments soll
auch ihr den rücken stärken
und jetzt nochmal zurück zum thema
corona auch manche tierarten sind ja
anfällig für das virus
und ob sie das dann auf den menschen
übertragen ist ungeklärt
brisant ist da vor allem die
massentierhaltung in dänemark wurden im
november wegen infektionen auf märz
farmen millionen tiere getötet märz
farmen für die pelzindustrie gibt es in
einigen ländern europas auch in polen
jutta sonne wald zeigt jetzt
erschreckende bilder die tierschützer
dort gemacht haben schon die haltung der
nerze in viel zu kleinen draht
verschlägen ist tierquälerei
das zeigen diese aufnahmen aus zwei nerz
farmen in polen heimlich aufgenommen von
deutschen und polnischen tierschützern
getötet werden sie in boxen mit gas
agrarlobby und pelzindustrie sagen das
geht schnell und sehr human
in wirklichkeit kämpfen die tiere
minutenlang im gas um ihr leben und
selbst nach 30 minuten wenn sich die
kiste öffnet kommen lebende tiere zum
vorschein die dann entweder brutal
erschlagen werden oder erneut ins gas
müssen diese haltung und tötung von
herzen und anderen pelztieren ist gang
und gäbe nicht nur in polen wo jedes
jahr fünf bis sechs millionen nerze
getötet werden
zwar haben die meisten europäischen
länder darunter deutschland pelz
tierzucht verboten doch polen finnland
und dänemark gehören nach wie vor zu den
größten pelz exporteuren europas die
wertvollen felle gehen vor allem nach
china wo sie zu kleidungsstücken
verarbeitet werden
tierschutzorganisationen fordern ein eu
weites verbot der pelztiere doch die eu
kommission sieht sich nicht in der
pflicht zu handeln
ich kann nicht über nationale
gesetzgebungen urteilen
es ist wichtig dass wir genau beobachten
was in diesen eu staaten passiert
die niederlande haben beschlossen schon
ende des jahres aus der nerz industrie
auszusteigen
in polen ringt die regierung um einen
entsprechenden gesetzesentwurf mit dem
parlament und der mächtigen pelz lobby
und jetzt in dieser sendung ganz anderes
thema in diesen minuten wird eines der
wichtigsten deutschen kulturprojekte
offiziell eröffnet das humboldt-forum
jahrzehntelang vorbereitet und errichtet
an historischem ort in berlin wo mal der
palast der republik stand die ddr
führung hatte ihn an die stelle des 1945
zerbombten schlosses gesetzt und nach
dessen vorbild steht dort jetzt das neue
stadtschlosses mit dem humboldt-forum
einem museum bei dem nicht nur die
äußere hülle stoff für diskussionen
bietet nadia nasa berichtet willkommen
im humboldtforum und das in vielen
sprachen der welt statt großer party ein
livestream zur eröffnung heute abend
experten und museumsmacher führen im
netz durch das mehr als 670 millionen
euro teure prestigeprojekt mehr war
corona bedingt zum start nicht möglich
der rundgang zeigt schlossgeschichte im
keller oder anklänge an den palast der
republik im treppenhaus die
rekonstruktion des barocken
hohenzollernschlosses bis heute heftig
diskutiert ich lade hier und heute
ausdrücklich die kritikerinnen und
skeptiker dieses projektes zur
mitwirkung ein
das humboldt forum soll ein ort werden
der vielfalt verbindet und
perspektivwechsel ermöglicht ein ort des
verstehens des gemeinsamen nachdenkens
und des gemeinsamen handelns in das
humboldt-forum sollen die nächste
objekte aus den ethnologischen und
asiatischen sammlungen einziehen
auch das kontrovers viele kunstwerke
wurden während der kolonialzeit
zusammengetragen was ist legal gekauft
was geraubt und was wird zurückgefordert
zum beispiel die benin großen erbeutet
im heutigen nigeria eine diskussion der
sich das haus stellen muss so ein haus
ist für die ewigkeit gebaut wollen wir
100 jahren
diese zeichen diese spuren diese objekte
des unrechts mitten im herzen von
unseren städten in europa haben die
hülle des humboldt forums ist zwar so
gut wie fertig doch im umgang mit den
inhalten steckt noch viel arbeit
sein leben war die musik wenn er einlud
dann sangen sie in massen
deutschlands wohl bekanntester
chorleiter gotthilf fischer ist
gestorben
musik ist das stärkste was menschen
verbindet sagt er einmal mit seinen
fischer chören wurde er ende der 60er
jahre weltweit bekannt es folgten
hunderte von auftritten wie der vor
einem millionen-publikum 1974 bei der
fußball-wm in münchen
gotthilf fischer wurde 92 jahre alt und
noch ein zitat von ihm chormusik ist ein
schritt näher zu gott und damit silber
in dieser sendung bei dir christine und
dem spruch bei uns ladies first seit 13
jahren warten die deutschen
handballerinnen auf eine medaille bei
einem großereignis
und auch diesmal bei der
europameisterschaft in kolding dänemark
steht das nationalteam früher aus als
erwartet
im letzten hauptrundenspiel verloren die
dhb frauen gegen die kroatinnen mit 20
wenn es um alles geht sind sie dem druck
nicht gewachsen so die bittere bilanz
des bundestrainers grüner nächstes
großes ziel die heim-wm 2025 ganz anders
die probleme bei den männern deren
weltmeisterschaft bereits in vier wochen
in ägypten beginnen soll
inzwischen gibt es sieben absagen 3
durch verletzungen und vier
nationalspieler verzichten freiwillig
wegen der korona pandemie bundes trainer
alfred gislasson ist nicht zu beneiden
vor allem die absage des weltklasse
abwehr innenblock hendrik pekeler und
patrick wiencek aus privaten gründen
trifft ihn hat ja mit der absage sind
aber natürlich um so stolz und glücklich
über die spielerinnen die deutschen
farben vertreten lassen
darin sollte die familien spielen die
hauptrolle bei den freiwilligen absagen
aber auch die angst vor der pandemie und
dem aufgeblähten turnier in ägypten dazu
gibt es eine verantwortung gegenüber den
vereinen zu allem überfluss soll es
jetzt direkt vor der wm zwei em
qualifikationsspiele gegen österreich
geben uns natürlich sehr recht wenn
dieses spiel nicht stattfinden würden
daran könnten wir einfach die quarantäne
für unsere spieler für die freiwillige
antenne dann auch anordnen noch sagen
bevor er zu uns kommt auch für eure
sieben tage kontaktfreie gehabt für eine
sichere zusammenkunft der
nationalmannschaft wäre das sicherlich
hilfreich auftaktsieg für
titelverteidiger peter wight bei der
weltmeisterschaft in london
gehandicapt durch einen rippenbruch
zeigte der 50-jährige schräge schotte
3 2 1 gegen den engländer steve coast
dennoch eine coole show allerdings
dürfen von morgen an keine zuschauer
mehr in den legendären erlebt wie schade
sagen die meisten aber so ist es halt
schräger schotte vielen dank christian
hoch hinaus gestartet sind die chinesen
dazu haben sie am 24 november eine sonde
zum mond geschickt und vor wenigen
minuten ist die wieder gelandet
in der inneren mongolei china ist damit
die dritte nation die nach den usa 1969
und der sowjetunion und 170 gestein vom
mond zurück auf die erde holt das ziel
der chinesen jetzt ein bemannter flug
zum mond
dann schauen wir noch auf die zahlen vom
mittwoch lotto und die lauten 12 17 19
22 48 superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen
auf lotto zdf de oder im zdf textseite
557 beim wetter wird es nass und das
hauptsächlich im norden deutschlands
mehr dazu hat gleich ist intelli ich
empfehle ihm das heute journal mit dem
kollegen claus kleber um 22 uhr heute
wir sagen dankeschön und gerne bis
morgen wenn sie mögen in allen aber
erstmal einen sehr angenehm
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter über dem atlantik
sind einige tiefs unterwegs und auch
über dem nordmeer ist dieses tief hier
unterwegs und das bringt und seine
occlusion front und die wandert einmal
vor allem über den norden deutschlands
in der zweiten nachthälfte kommt diese
front im nordwesten an und bringt regen
über der deutschen bucht gibt es
stürmischen wind aus süd ansonsten
südlich des mains bildet sich
hauptsächlich in gewässernähe dann teils
dichter nebel mit temperaturen von minus
drei grad an den alpen null grad an der
donau und 9 grad am oberrhein
morgen also nördlich der mittelgebirge
viele wolken mit regen die allmählich
ostwärts ziehen nach osten in richtung
erzgebirge durchaus sonnenschein und
auch an den alpen aber an der donau oder
bleibt es wahrscheinlich den ganzen tag
dicht bei höchsten temperaturen von zwei
grad an der donau und 12 grad am
oberrhein
die kommenden tage gehen mit hochdruck
weiter ruhig weiter viel sonnenschein im
südwesten ansonsten viele wolken im
osten bei drei bis elf grad am samstag
steigt die temperatur im westen
deutschlands bis auf 14 grad und sonntag
kommt von westen etwas regen auf damit
ein schöner abend